on va parler de cette nomination de
Gabriel Atal puisqueavant de se rendre
dans le Pas de calis Gabriel Atal a donc
pris les reennes de Matignon passation
pouvoir avec ellisabeth borne on voit ça
avec Marion
dalpèche à 34 ans matigon s'offre à lui
Gabriel hatal succède à Élizabeth borne
et devient le plus jeune premier
ministre de la République le plus jeune
président de la République de l'histoire
nomme le plus jeune premier ministre de
l'histoire je ne veux y voir qu'un seul
symbole celui de l'audace et du
mouvement macroniste de la première
heure fin politique il résume sa méthode
déjà employée dans ses précédentes
fonctions poser des diagnostics clairs
sans jamais mentir au français et mettre
en place des actions fortes concrètes
sans tabout dire la vérité agir sans
attendre voilà ce que sera mon action à
la tête du gouvernement de la France
avec le président de la République
j'aurais donc un objectif garder le
contrôle de notre destin et libér notre
potentiel français alors que les
syndicats déplorent déjà son passager
clair à l'éducation nationale le nouveau
locataire de matigon dit sa
détermination à poursuivre son travail
amorcé ces 6 derniers mois au ministère
de l'Éducation j'emène avec moi ici à
matigon la cause de l'école je réaffirme
l'école comme étant la mère de nos
batailles celle qui doit être au cœur de
nos priorités et à qui je donnerai comme
premier ministre tous lesy d'action
nécessaire pour sa réussite elle sera
l'une de mes priorités absolu dans mon
action à la tête du gouvernement Gabriel
a remercié le chef de l'État tout comme
Elisabeth born qui annonce son retour à
l'Assemblée nationale le nouveau
locataire de matigon doit désormais
former un gouvernement hier soir un
objectif de resserrement du nombre de
ministres a déjà été évoqué lors d'un
dîner avec le chef de l'État Nicolas pr
est-ce que cette nomination de Gabriel
c'est un coup politique pour Emmanuel
Macron ici oui est-ce qu'il est réussi
c'est un coup politique majeur et et
bien sûr il est réussi alors il est
réussi parce que là on est au lendemain
de de cette nomination il a un effet de
surprise Gabriel hatal c'était un nom
sur la liste mais c'était pas le premier
on nous avait pendant le weekend donner
les noms plutôt de Sébastien Lecornu ou
de Julien de Normandie B maintenant tout
ça c'est de l'histoire ancienne et c'est
la nomination de de Gabriel tal qui
permet de donner pour le président de la
République un effet de surprise donc de
de concentrer et de focaliser attention
on se demandant mais qu'est-ce qui va se
passer maintenant avec ce plus jeune
premier ministre de la 5e République
est-ce qu'il est pas trop jeune est-ce
qu'il a assez d'expérience il y a
beaucoup de questions qui se posent et
puis euh le fait aussi que les attentes
sont concentrées parce que Gabriel Atal
a ces derniers mois plutôt réussi son
passage même s'il est inabouti au
ministère de de l'éducation nationale
donc le coup politique plutôt réussi
maintenant le plus dur commence quel
ministre quelle équipe quelle feuille de
route et puis des élections européennes
je pense qu'on va en parler en qui
s'annonce particulièrement compliqué
pour le pouvoirû coup politique réussi
je crois que vous invitez quelqu'un sur
ce plateau assez régulièrement Arnaud
Benedetti qui a écrit ce livre assez
passionnant le coup de Come permanent et
effectivement on est dans le coup de
comme permanent avec un avec une
nouveauté parce que je je trouve que
depuis 2017 au moins dans la nomination
de Gabriel Atal Emmanuel Macron fait un
choix extrêmement politique c'estàdire
que qu'il était qu'il était question
de de Philippe Édouard Philippe Jean
Castex ou ellisabeth borne personne ne
connaissait aucun de ces trois
prédécesseurs et il faisait plutôt le
choix de profil plus techno là au moins
avec effectivement Gabriel LAL il fait
un choix très politique très politique
d'une personnalité qui effectivement
dans les sondage semble avoir une bonne
code de popularité même si je crois pas
que les Français connaissent encore
véritablement le visage de Gabriel Atal
et puis parce que euh bien que j'ai
plein de désaccords avec lui il faut
reconnaître que depuis 2017 euh il est
un excellent politique et il est
redoutablement intelligent euh en
matière de communication Nicolas disait
qu'il avait un bilan plutôt positif en
tout cas qu' s'en était plutôt bien
peine à sair pouro on dit qu'il a un B
bilan qu'il a plutôt réussi son passage
à l'éducation nationale parce que lui
aussi c'est un c'est un c'est un
excellent communiquant à la à la Macron
c'est quand même un mini Macron en fait
qu'Emmanuel Macron a nommé il a nommé
son mini mois presque mais je peux pas
dire que on peut pas dire qu'il a un
bilan politique gabrielal à part avoir
suivi et
avoir soutenu les les les gouvernements
dans lesquels il a appartenu on peut pas
dire qu' par qui est pas non plus
quelque chose qui a révolutionné la vie
des enseignants ni des élèves on peut
pas dire qu'il ait un bilan politique
qui a changé fondamentalement la vie des
gens ou des personnes pour lesquelles il
a travaillé donc on va attendre voir
évidemment je trouve que la seule bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'effectivement il fait
enfin un choix très politique et on le
sait la raison pour laquelle il le fait
c'est sans doute la question des
européennes qui obnubile Emmanuel Macron
il y a pas que la question des des
européennes et du bilan alors le bilan
effectivement on peut pas le dresser au
bout de de 5 mois c'est beaucoup trop
court et vous avez raison sur ce pointl
en revanceche il a une personnalité
politique qui il a pu affirmer et et
faire apprécier en seulement quelques
mois au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale mais il avait déjà aussi fait
parler de lui Gabriel LAL avant d'être
ministre deucation nationale et avant
cette décision un peu fondatrice dans
son CV qui est celle sur la BAA
notamment à l'Assemblée quand il allait
porter le faer contre les oppositions
c'est aussi un de ses talents c'est une
façon de de d'incarner la politique à la
Macron que une partie de l'entourage du
chef de l'État ou de la majorité pouvait
reprocher à ellisabeth Bor autour
d'Emmanuel Macron disait ces derniers
jours il faut une incarnation il faut
quelqu'un qui soit capable d'être sur le
terrain d'aller euh affronter les
opposition et notamment le rassemblement
national et ça Gabriel hatal en peu de
mois a a réussi à montrer qu'il avait
les capacités pour pour répondre à ces à
ces demandes et à ces exigences qui sont
un peu la moindre des choses en
politique et donc parmi tous les CV qui
étaient présentés au président de la
République celui-là finit par s'imposer
parce qu' il cochait toutes les cases et
puis il y a aussi bon c'est la petite
histoire mais des jeux d'appareils et
des jeux de pouvoir autour du président
de la République qui ont se sont
notamment François Baayou opposés à la
nomination de de Sébastien le Cornu mais
bon il y a des bras de fer internes à la
majorité et finalement Gabriel Atal
apparaît comme la solution qui permet un
peu de rassembler nous tout le monde
même si ça grince un peu des dents dans
les les partis partenaires on va parler
de la majorité dans dans quelques ZES
Nicolas mais quel intérêt politique pour
Emmanuel Macron de nommer Gabriel hatal
qui est un ministre qui était qui est
pour le moment très populaire alors que
jusque là il il a nommé des premier
ministres très peu connus qui lui
faisait pas don la question est pasant
celle de la personnalité dans un premier
temps même si elle compte vraiment que
celle du timing le timing c'est un
remanimement qui intervient après la
crise autour de la loi immigration et
surtout 6 mois avant les Européennes et
pour la majorité en tout cas pour le
président de la République et son
entourage ce qui était très important
c'est de pouvoir relancer la machine à
un moment où la campagne s'annonce
extrêmement compliquée où les sondages
donnent quand même une défaite pour
Renaissance au lieu de le faire le
lendemain des européennes qui aurait été
le calendrier le plus classique en
politique une élection on en tire les
conséquences on change de premier minist
ont fait un remanimement mais là ça
aurait été une élection un remanimement
pardon défensif après une défaite et
pour conjurer le sort en quelque sorte
et puisess de se donner de de nouvelles
chances il y a cette relance qui est
faite avec la personnalité dont on vient
de parler pour essayer de de de
redresser la barre et d'avoir le moins
mauvais score aux européennes et pas
être obligé de faire un remanement
défensif à la sortie et on va voir ce ce
sondage odoxa pour Le Figaro 53 % des
Français approuvent la nomination de
Gabriel hatal est-ce qu'il est la bonne
personne pour relancer le quinen
d'Emmanuel Macron pierre j'en Saens rien
et ça me fait sourire parce que je je
suppose qu'on a interrogé des des sans
doute quelques centaines de personnes
pour savoir si si il approuva la
nomination de Gabriel qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que les gens
vous répondent à ce type de question je
sais pas de quelle manière a été posée
la question je pense que d'abord une
partie des gens ne connaissent pas
Gabriel at même si on le dit populaire
même si on le dit accessible c'est quand
quand quand on dit populaire quand on
est journaliste on sait très bien ce que
ce que ça peut vouloir dire et c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs il a plutôt une
bonne code de popularité y compris dans
les oppositions vous prenez le le le le
patron de la commission des finances à
l'Assemblée nationale Éric coocrel qui
vient de la France insoumise il en dit
plutôt du bien de Gabriel il le trouve
intelligent il le trouve c'est c'est
vrai on le sait Gabriel est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement
travailleur même s'il n'a pas selon moi
la colonne vertébrale que j'aimerais
qu'un homme politique et avec une
constance politique qui aurait dû être
la sienne en tant que venant de de la
gauche voilà c'est ça ça pe parrêter
donc je sais pas s'il est la bonne
personne en tout cas je trouve
qu'Emmanuel Macron pour une fois lui qui
est si mauvais DRH fait un bon choix
parce qu'il fait un choix politique que
Gabriel Atal va faire de la politique
que il nomme un chef de gouvernement
politique pour faire de la politique
notamment dans un contexte où il va y
avoir l'échéance des européennes d'ici 6
mois effectivement je pense qu'Emmanuel
Macron a une obsession c'est qu'après
lui il n'y ait pas l'extrême droite qui
prenne le pouvoir donc il pense que
Gabriel Atal avec son profil jeune peut
être un challenger à Jordan Bardella qui
fait la course très largement en tête
avec 10 points d'avance sur selon ce
qu'on estime dans les sondages la seule
erreur qui pour moi euh il risque d'être
un frein quand même assez fort pour
Gabri Gabriel LAL c'est que un il va
sans doute faire les frais de
l'immobilisme politique parce qu'il y a
toujours pas de majorité dans ce dans ce
pays et de c'est pas la jeunesse de
gabrielal qui va faire le front qui va
faire le rempart à l'extrême droite il
va falloir un qu'il y a un changement de
cap or la mauvaise nouvelle de de cette
nomination de Gabriel LAL c'est que elle
ne signifie pas un changement de cap
elle signifie seulement un changement de
de stratégie avec avec sans doute des
effets de com quelqu'un qui parle bien
et qui fait de la politique et qui va
sans doute manœuvrer pendant cette
campagne électorale et là pour la peine
encore une fois il est le moins il est
sans doute le moins mauvais pour pour
assurer le job il faut pas attendre de
changement de cap Nicolas c'est même un
retour au macronisme historique Gabriel
Atal il faut attendre son discours de
politique générale on sait pas quelle
est sa feuille de route on sait qu'il y
a dans le calendrier des étapes qui ont
été posé par Emmanuel Macron et lesib
borne l'IVG dans la Constitution la fin
fin de vie une réforme de la fonction
publique qui qui se présente donc il y a
des choses qui sont à balisé une loi
qu'on dit pacte 2 de simplification pour
les les entreprise donc ces éléments ils
sont posés il devrait pas forcément
donner lieu à de de grosses divergences
de gros combats euh politique encore que
la fin de vie si prête euh mais surtout
pour le gouvernement il y a la question
de savoir quel sera d'une part le
casting et quells seront d'autre part
les les objectifs au quotidien les
objectifs concrets parce que c'est ça
dont on vous parle dans l'entourage du
du président de la République c'est
d'avoir des des des problèmes à résoudre
rapidement et et de façon claire et
perceptible pour les gens ce type de
discours qui un peu permanent depuis le
début du quinena et même du premier
quinena mais il y a cet objectif pour
pour Gabriel Atal qui lui a été donné de
d'aller sur le terrain on l'a vu hier
dans le pas decalis et donner des
réponses le plus rapidement possible aux
Français et et au français alors quels
seront les thèmes les éléments sur
lesquels le gouvernement va aller auquel
le gouvernement va s'attaquer le plus
vite possible ça il faut falloir
attendre encore quelques jours pour le
savoir peut-être la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée devant les députés il y a
deux choses qui ont présidé je pense à à
la décision d'Emmanuel Macron justement
d'aller à l'encontre y compris de ses
proches qui était pas favorable vous
citiez vous citiez François Baayou je
crois il y a quelques temps quelques
instants on sait très bien que dans son
entourage proche y compris dans son
cabinet leexic coler n'y était pas
favorable d'autres Richard Ferrand lui
ont dit qu' bon il avait une
bienveillante bien en regard à son égard
mais il avait plutôt un choix différent
mais mais donc il y a deux choses qui
ont présidé à ce choix d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est à la fois les l'élection
effectivement européenne mais en plus de
ça c'est aussi l'après Macron qui se
dessine c'est-à-dire que on sait on sait
très bien que aujourd'hui les les les
différents conflits qui existent au sein
de la majorité ils sont pas liés à
est-ce que ce Ken va bien se terminer
mais plutôt à l'après Emmanuel Macron la
colère de Gérald dermanin ou la colère
de Bruno Le Maire avec cette nomination
elle est liée au fait que eux deux
s'estiment possiblement les plus
légitimes en tout cas pour assurer la la
la la la suite d'Emmanuel Macron en 2027
mais le le le combat d'Emmanuel Macron
qui qui est celui de qui semble vouloir
donner comme comme rôle à à Gabriel Atal
qui est celui de battre l'extrême droite
il faut que Gabriel Atal fasse attention
à une chose qui me paraît fondamentale
c'est que c'est pas en allant sur le
terrain d'extrême droite qu'on combat
l'extrême droite or Gabriel Atal et
c'est même Louis Aliot qui l'a dit hier
dans une chaîne concurrente Gabriel Atal
a piqué nos idées donc Gabriel Atal a
piqué les idées du RN c'est vrai que la
BAA c'est pas franchement une idée très
enfin en tout cas l'interdiction de la
baaya c'est pas franchement une idée
très progressiste la question de
l'uniforme à l'école c'est pas non plus
une idée très progressiste et la loi
immigration c'est pas une idée
progressiste c'est d'ailleurs cette loi
immigration avec la décision qui va être
celle du Conseil constitutionnel ça va
être sans doute une des premières
grandes décisions que Gabriel Atal va
être amené à prendre si le Conseil
constitutionnel devait censurer une
dizaine de ces articles y compris les
plus importants que fera Gabriel Atal
face à la à la mobilisation qui est en
train de se se mettre en place d'ici à
la fin du mois avec les syndicats les
partis politiques l'opposition les
grandes ONG contre cette loi que
fera-t-il est-ce qu'il comp continuera
de cliver ou est-ce qu'il essaiera
justement d'être celui qui va un peu
pacifier le contexte qui est déjà
suffisamment tendu et justement on va
voir que l'un des défis de Gabriel hatal
ça va être de ressouder la majorité
voire de l'élargir elles vont pas être
simples les prochaines semaines de
Gabriel hatal Steve la donne politique
n'a pas changé non la vitrine a changé
mais la boutique reste la même il va
falloir la faire tourner rappelez-vous
en mars 2023 on est en plein cœur de la
bataille des retraite Emmanuel Macron
conforte ellisabeth borne tout en lui
fixant cette mission le mandat que j'ai
donné c'est de continuer à élergir cette
majorité autant qu'elle le pourra
j'espère qu'elle y parviendra choublanc
la réforme est finalement adoptée par un
passage en force VI à 493 et puis même
exercice d'équilibrisme lors de la loi
la loi immigration des tractations ont
lieu avec les alr pendant de longs mois
résultat et moralité oui vous pouvez
obtenir les votes de la droite et même
de l'extrême droite mais vous risquez
alors de perdre des voix dans votre
propre camp au moment du vote fin
décembre au sein de la majorité
présidentielle une trentaine de députés
votent contre le texte immigration bref
le Premier ministre change mais
l'arithmétique politique est éue Gabriel
Atal sera confronté au même problème à
la même équation qu'Élisabeth borne hier
il a quand même tendu la main aux
oppositions écoutez aux oppositions je
leur dis que nous avons en commun le
destin de notre nation que nous ne
serons évidemment pas d'accord sur tout
que nous nous opposerons mais aussi je
leur fais la promesse de toujours les
écouter toujours les respecter parce
qu'à travers eux c'est la voix de
millions de Français qui
s'expriment avec des dossiers compliqués
sur la table si oui notamment le dossier
de l'Ame l'aide médicale d'État que le
Sénat vous en souvenez vousou l'IT
supprimé dans cette loi immigration on
souvient aussi qu'Élisabeth borne avait
promis un LR de remettre le dossier sur
la table au mois de janvier promesse qui
avait même été faite par courrier envoyé
à Gérard Larcher la droite attend donc
le nouveau Premier ministre au tournant
écoutez le président du Sénat c'était ce
matin sur TF1 nous traversons une crise
du logement extrêmement
grave nous avons des problèmes de
réponse de santé dans une grande partie
du territoire et vis-à-vis des Français
vous savez on a eu 6 ministres de la
Santé en 6 ans moi j'appelle à la
stabilité à la stabilité pour ouvrir des
perspectives ben sur le logement il faut
voir tous les toutes les causes de
blocage donner le pouvoir aux élus
locaux il faut donner vous ne vous
sortirez pas de la crise du logement
sans retracer et retisser une voie de
confiance avec les élus locaux et quels
sont les autres dossiers St la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG par
exemple un grand chantier des mois à
venir l'entrée de l'IVG dans la
Constitution on s'en souvient promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron l'Assemblée nationale
se penche sur un projet de loi
constitutionnel dès le 24 janvier s'il
est adopté ensuite il faudra que le
texte soit voté dans les mêmes termes
ici au Sénat et c'est pas gagné puis
qu'un congrès réuni à Versailles valide
ce même texte ça devrait être autour de
début mars autre grand R rendez-vous
pour l'exécutif l'adoption d'une loi sur
la fin de vie là encore promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron les contours devraient
être dévoilés au mois de février ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il n aura pas une
mais deux lois la première sur le
développement des soins palliatifs la
seconde sur l'aide à mourir deux lois
plutôt qu'une ça fait deux fois plus de
soucis pour Gabriel atthal
ou Nicolas est-ce que le plus grand défi
de Gabriel Atal dans les prochaines
semaines ça va être un de consolider sa
propre majorité et de de l'élargir
est-ce que c'est le le meilleur premier
ministre pour faire ça alors pour
consolider j'ai c'est plutôt bien parti
parce que Gabriel natal n'a pas vraiment
d'ennemi au sein du du groupe
Renaissance et il est plutôt bien perçu
il est macroniste depuis la première
heure donc son sa nomination est est
voilà elle nature a un peu rassurer tout
le monde après vis-à-vis des oppositions
évidemment et même juste avec le Modem
et avec horizon oui ça alors modem et
horizon qui était pas forcément
favorable à ce que ce soit lui ça a été
dit en coulisse Édouard Philippe et et
et et François baayerou qui avait
d'autres options bon là il va falloir
rassurer les uns et les autres mais pour
ça il y a une nomination desomination à
attendre au gouvernement donc ça peut
être aussi une façon pour Emmanuel
Macron de de voilà de calmer les les les
irritations et puis de de de récompenser
des des membres de de de modem ou
d'horizon ça sera nécessairement le cas
faudra voir dans quelle proportion on
scrutera ça évidemment avec intérêt en
ce qui concerne les oppositions là la
problématique elle reste entière et
c'est exactement la même que celle que
devait affronter ellisabeth borne
comment arriver à trouver des majorités
au cas par cas on entendu hier que
Gabriel Matal y allait voilà de bonne
volonté la main la main tendue encore
faut-il que en face je pense notamment
au républicains il y ait aussi cette
volonté de de de construire on a vu que
ça n'avait pas été le cas ou que c'était
extrêmement compliqué pendant un an et
demi pour Elisabeth born il y a aucune
raison que ça soit plus simple pour
Gabriel Atal je même ça devrait être
encore plus compliqué puisque on est en
on entre en période électorale et et les
républicains sont face à un danger un
péril mortel avec ces élections
européennes desquelles ils peuvent
sortir totalement les civé donc le
climat le temps est pas forcément
favorable à la coalition à l'accord à la
discussion et c'est pour ça qu'on
devrait plutôt voir Gabriel hatal et ses
ministres agir soit par voie
réglementaire ou alors des effets
d'annonce essayer de trouver des des
solutions et et des cas pratiques qui
soient pas de nature législative alors
justement vous en parliez tous les deux
la la prochaine électorale ce sont les
Européennes du 9 juin est-ce que la
nomination de Gabriel hatal c'est aussi
une manière pour Emmanuel Macron de
signifier qu'il n'enjamb pas ses
élections est-ce que Gabrielle Atal
c'est la meilleure arme
antirassemblement national euh on verra
les preuvve desfit mais c'est c'est vrai
que quand je disais que la bonne
nouvelle dans le profil choisi par
Emmanuel Macron pour le poste de Premier
ministre c'est que on a là enfin
quelqu'un qui fait de la politique
quelqu'un qui sait gérer des campagnes
électorales et qui sait affronter une
campagne électorale comme celle des
européennes y compris parce que les
enjeux ils sont colossaux c'est on voit
les sondages après sondage donner
une une importante victoire à l'extrême
droite de on va voir un d'ailleurs c'est
le sondage odoxa pour Public Sénat qui
est sorti mi-décembre et qui donne 10
points d'écart entre la liste de la
majorité présidentielle et celle de
Jordan Bardella donc sans doute ça va
être ce qui va occuper et préoccuper
Gabriel c'est de conduire une majorité
dans le cadre de ces élections
européennes et d'essayer de
battre extrême droite même si le le le
le ça ça semble un peu compliqué je je
rappelais une chose tout à l'heure mais
qui me paraît fondamentale c'està-d que
on on combat évidemment le l'extrême
droite sur le terrain des idées mais on
va pas sur le terrain de ces idées
c'est-à-dire que ce qu'a fait Emmanuel
Macron jusqu'à maintenant en agitant le
chiffon rouge de l'immigration et en
faisant en reprenant pour partie les
propositions de l'extrême droite je suis
pas sûr on a toujours dit qu'on
préférait l'original à la copie donc
c'est c'est c'est ça qui attend Gabriel
mais encore une fois je trouve que euh
c'est c'est plutôt intelligent de de la
part d'Emmanuel Macron de que d'avoir
voulu politiser la fonction qui est
celle qu'il a toujours donné au Premier
ministre qui était celle d'un grand
collaborateur qui était celle de de de
de de quelqu'un qui ne décide pas et
c'est peut-être là que vont apparaître
d'ailleurs possiblement j'en sais rien
peut-être sont-ils suffisamment liés
tous les deux on le sait d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont plutôt liés mais peut-être
que les premières tensions risquent de
de se faire jour parce que je je je
pense que Gabriel Atal va vouloir
imprimer sa marque de Premier ministre
pouvoir prendre des décisions et donc
faire de la politique ce que attend
génér d' chef de gouvernement je
rappelle que c'est lui qui conduit et
qui conduit la politique du gouvernement
même si évidemment le président de la
République a toujours son mot à dire et
et d'ailleurs dès son discours
d'investiture hier dès la passation de
pouvoir Gabriel hatal a dit qu'il
fallait renforcer notre souveraineté
nationale notre souverité européenne en
maîtrisant mieux notre immigration
est-ce qu'il a lancé déjà dier la
campagne des européennes de la majorité
en allant sur le Canau de Jordan
Bardella oui bien sûr il a eu cette
phrase très importante à mon avis dans
dans ce discours qui était pas très long
c'est garder le contrôle de notre destin
garder le contrôle ou reprendre le
contrôle k back TAKE BACK control
c'était le slogan des des brexiteurs et
ce vocabulaire il revient souvent y
compris dans la majorité en disant ce ce
slogan il a fonctionné il peut
fonctionner quand on le place sous le
terrain de sur le terrain de de la
souveraineté souveraineté européenne on
sait c'est les mots d'Emmanuel Macron
dès ses premiers discours concernant
l'Europe dans son premier quinquena donc
garder le contrôle pour Gabriel atas
c'est une forme de de slogan euh ça
s'oppose évidemment au rassemblement
national et ça sera je pense un des de
ces actes de de de campagne il y a les
mots et puis a aussi les images et la
personnalité on on vient de l'évoquer
Gabriel Atal c'est le plus jeune premier
ministre de la 5e République et et il
aura face à lui si j'ose dire Jordan
Bardella qui a 28 ans et donc on a une
génération qui va s'affronter et qui est
aussi pour Emmanuel Macron façon de
montrer que il a des ressources on a
souvent dit qu'il avait pas de bande
touche et qu'il était pas en cap
capacité d'aller chercher des
personnalités pour affronter les
oppositions ben là il a avec Gabriel
Atal quelqu'un dont on a vu la capacité
à forger des slogans avoir des des
éléments de langage fort et c'est vrai
que cette opposition générationnelle et
idéologique ça va être ce qui va
captiver notre ascention ces prochains
mois parce que on on a jamais vu ce
match là et il et il a 6 mois pour faire
une chose que ses prédécesseurs presque
ses prédécesseurs n'ont pas fait c'est
assumer un discours de politique
générale et assumer vis-à-vis des
oppositions le vote d'une confiance je
pense que il est suffisamment habile
pour ne pas y échapper et surtout là où
Emmanuel Maron nous promet à chaque fois
de changer sur la méthode là aussi il
est suffisamment politique et habile
pour nous proposer un changement de
méthode avec les organisations syndicale
et le traitement du Parlement et on
continue à parler de Gabriel à tal
puisqu'il est à la une de nos quotidiens
régionaux ce
[Musique]
matin
et à la une de nos quotidiens régionaux
ce matin c'est le nouveau Premier
ministre oui difficile de passer à côté
gabrielal fait la Une de beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de quotidien l'UR
républicain revient sur son assenion
fulgurante charent li parle de coup de
jeûe à Matignon même insistant sur l'âge
du Premier ministre 34 ans pour le
Courrier Picard La Dépêche du Midi voit
elle en Gabriel Atal l'homme du
président et pas de temps à perdre pour
Gabriel Atal un premier déplacement
effectué dans la foulée de sa nomination
direction le pas de calis au côté de des
sinistrés des inondations ça fait la une
de la voie du Nord ce matin personne ne
va vous oublier à assurer Gabriel Atal
devant des élus il a annoncé plusieurs
mesures et a promis de revenir sur place
dans un mois pour faire le point il a
aussi promis un suivi hebdomadaire de la
situation premier déplacement et donc
premier première promesse pour le
Premier ministre et comment va-t-il
gouverner c'est la question c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose ça
fait la une du Dauphiné notamment ce
matin il est en tout cas chargé de
donner un un nouveau souffle au second
quinen Macron mais autre question aussi
ce ma matin avec qui va-t-il gouverner
quelle sera la composition du nouveau
gouvernement beaucoup d'attentes à
l'heure où l'on se parle attente
notamment de Christophe Béchu qui fait
la une du Courrier de l'Ouest l'ancien
sénateur est toujours ministre de la
transition écologique il était
d'ailleurs au côté de Gabriel Atal hier
lors du déplacement dans le pas decalais
peut-être peut-être un premier signe
d'un maintien au gouvernement en tout
cas lui vote pour il a un autre sujet
dans la presse régionale ce sont les
soldes les soldes oui les soldes divers
soldes divers top départ aujourd'hui et
si le grand à qui frappe actuellement la
France était une bonne nouvelle pour les
commerçants c'est la question que pose
l'Union ce matin qui répond que oui ce
froid est sans doute un atout réponse
dans les prochains jours pour l'instant
c'est pas forcément gagné he puisque 57
% des Français selon un sondage Ifop
envisage de ne pas participer au sol de
divers j' dirais les faire peut-être on
a un mois en tout cas pour les faire ça
ça laisse de la marche pierre à la Une
de Politi pour Macron le plein emploi
quoi qu'il en coûte oui on revient sur
cette obsession macroniste qui consiste
à à réformer en permanence les
l'assurance chômage notamment pour
ramener les gens vers l'emploi ou en
tout cas les ramener de manière un peu
biaisée les gens vers l'emploi quoi
qu'il en coûte jusqu'à ce que l'on crée
une génération de travailleurs pauvres
àire d' Politi qu'est-ce que vous nous
préparez dans la tribune dimanche
Nicolas beaucoup de choses du
remanimement et du nouveau gouvernement
bien sûr évidemment Gabriel
Atal ça va nous occuper ces prochains
jours et et on espère apporter beaucoup
d'information on lira ça dimanche avec
attention merci beaucoup Nicolas pr
merci
merci Steve nous on se retrouve demain
et à 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec
Thomas pour sence public très bonne
journée